franchement volant bonsoir
bonne année merci alors vous avez pris
de bonnes résolutions j'imagine pour
l'année 2005 de ne pas retourner en irak
pas dans l'immédiat pas dans l'immédiat
donc de plus faire la une du 20 heures
mais voilà sa vie dans ses parents
n'étaient pas volontaires pour pour ce
rôle de danseuse parfois ce qui
ressemblait un peu à un très mauvais
film en tous les cas après 11 ans
d'expatriation vous aviez décidé de
revenir en france fin 2004 des bulles
2005 c'est fait c'est ce que vous aviez
premier à sylvie oui y'a qu'à leur m
vous êtes à l'heure avec un petit peu de
retard vous êtes les promesses voilà en
tous les cas on est très heureux de vous
voir on s'est fait beaucoup de souci
pour vous et on est très très heureux de
vous avoir
21 décembre ça leur a pas laissé
beaucoup de temps chez vous pour acheter
des cadeaux de noël oui c'est vrai je
crois que mon retour était quand même le
plus beau des cadeaux de noël quoi donc
ça tombait bien vous allez passer les
fêtes chez vous à monter guéant voilà
forez il ya très longtemps que j'étais
pas rentrer pour un noël souvent je
restais au moyen-orient et cette année
c'était un petit peu de vin
circonstances exceptionnelles et j'y
retrouvais un village où j'ai passé mon
enfance et c'était assez impressionnant
parce que il y avait beaucoup de visages
les pas revu depuis très longtemps j'y
pensais d'ailleurs quand j'étais en
détention j'avais besoin de me rassurer
10,2 d'image sécurisante comme ça alors
on pense à la à la maison de campagne
qui qui qui nous attend ou alors aux
amis d'enfance alors que bon avant j'y
pensais pas trop au jeu à temps j'avais
quitté la région et a pris de la valeur
pour vous ça a pris de la valeur des ce
qui peut rassurer quand on est dans la
sécurité vous croyez à nouveau père noël
maintenant
absolument d'ailleurs on se disait début
décembre avec christian chez nous disons
on va être libéré juste avant noël parce
que bon ça fera un beau un beau cadeau
ça a été un très beau cadeau pour tout
le monde
alors vous vos conditions de captivité
ont été ont été très dures quand même
nous étions enfermés dans des pièces
hermétique avec une une chaleur torride
nourriture minimum ou manger quoi on
mangeait on a commencé par si je puis
dire les des produits du terroir puis on
était dans une ferme les les quinze
premiers jours on avait on a mangé
beaucoup de deux dates de korn grecque
et des beaucoup de thé c'était on
perdait 1 kg par semaine mais bon
c'était assez c'était assez nourrissant
quand même et ensuite on est passé dirai
pas ce fou de local c'était du kebab et
du poulet riz et ensuite lors d'un
transfert on a on est on est passé à la
la la cuisine irakienne traditionnel qui
est bonne donc vous avez pas souffert de
maintenant conscient non on a été assez
bien traités au point de vue
alimentation alors parfois on avait dû
on avait des des pizza froide au petit
déjeuner le matin santé c'est un petit
peu difficile mais globalement on a été
bien traité de ce point de vue en tous
les cas vous n'êtes pas été victimes de
violences ou donnant simulation
d'exécution n'y a pas une simulacre
d'exécution n'y a pas eu dans la reçues
jacques à une gifle ses taux au début
mais il n'y a pas eu cette pression
physique il ya eu des pressions
psychologiques bien sûr mais pas
physique vous ne saviez pas que les
mêmes qui vous détenait avait assassiné
le journaliste italien enzo baldoni vous
saviez pas ça on l'a su trois semaines
environ après notre capture lorsque le
18 septembre les responsables de de
l'armée islamique est venu nous voir et
pour nous dire qu'on allait libérer la
semaine suivante et nous à dire
d'ailleurs au moment où vous à capturer
ou la capture est aussi un italien
journalistes mais en fait c'était pas un
vrai journaliste selon eux c'était un
espion et on lui a coupé la tête et il
nous a dit à ce moment là les français d
très inquiet
ginier quand même que la france mobilisé
pour vous vous avez déjà vécu vous savez
comment ça se passe quand les des otages
français qui sont capturés on en parle
tous les jours aux journaux ou ça vous
saviez que vous ont par les buttes
chaque jour que vous porterez été
placardées sur l'hôtel de ville ou non
ça en lisant on le savait pas mais on
vous imaginiez en tout cas la
modélisation
mobilisation et puis nos ravisseurs nous
disait par exemple vous êtes connus
enfin alors on leur disait rien c'était
pas vraiment notre préoccupation et il
nous disait effectivement le ministre
des affaires étrangères a appelé à votre
libération sentait au moment où c'était
très chaud en france on sentait que les
signaux qui était émis par le
gouvernement français d'envoyer barnier
dans la région de l'appel de chirac le
soir à la télévision
eh bien ces signaux ont été reçus par
nos ravisseurs qui attendait justement
ce genre de de signaux et qui qui leur
donnaient à penser que la france ne nous
laisserait pas tomber accorder de
l'importance à don à ces deux
journalistes parce que ce qu'ils disent
qui a rien de pire c'est de d'avoir
justement des ravisseurs qui lancent des
appels comme ça un gouvernement qui ne
répondent pas de journalistes qui flotte
dans l'air et puis bon bah au bout d'un
certain temps ouais alors finalement le
plus dur de toute votre détention ça a
été les déplacements vous aviez les les
yeux bandés vous étiez ligoté dans une
espèce de cercueils en carton à
l'arrière de d'un gmc ça c'était
désagréable c'est assez désagréable
parce que d'une part quand on vous
transfère on vous rend vous ligotant
vous bande les yeux vous savez pas où
vous allez la première fois et puis
effectivement on vous glisse dans une
espèce de deux cercueils en carton
recouvert de deux kilos de couverture
pour passer inaperçu et puis vous avez
le vous avez juste la tête qu'il ait pas
c'est donc ça c'était assez c'est assez
angoissant et lors d'un des transferts
par exemple on a même crevé et donc là
on s'est dit c'était déjà au bout d'un
certain temps là je me suis dit s'il
pourrait y avoir une patrouille
américaine qui passe et qui embarque
tout ce beau monde et puis en même temps
je me suis dit si jamais il ya les
américains ils vont nous prendre comme
bouclier humain donc c'est vraiment bon
on est un peu fataliste on attend que ça
se passe quoi donc c'était c'était assez
c'est assez flippant quand même ça
c'était quoi le pire moment de votre
captivité le pire moment ça a été le
lundi à partir du lundi 8 novembre
lorsque
des responsables de l'armée islamique
est venu nous voir de mauvaise humeur il
a arraché un calendrier qui était sur le
bureau nous a dit la situation est très
grave
vous pouvez tuer tout moment les
français sont était donc qu'ils allaient
faire une cassette appelant le
gouvernement français a à résoudre notre
problème donc à partir de là on passe il
angoisse parce qu'on a je pense qu'on
pense qu'on peut être tué on n'a pas eu
de chance parce que deux jours après il
ya eu des bombardements juste autour
donc le lendemain on nous a transférés
en le transférant nous glisse à
l'oreille que que les français n'ont pas
compris la menace et puis en nous
sortant justement du gmc après le mans
se faire le lol le chauffeur nous dit en
anglais qui est mort qui est vivant donc
là on se dit bon bah ils vont ils vont
ils vont exécuter un et et ils vont
apporter la tête de celui qui va être
exécuté aux français pour qu'ils voient
leur mieux rires c'était ça ce qu'ils
ont tué 1 voilà comme exemple encore un
exemple et pour dire aux français
maintenant ben fait ce qu'il faut pour
sauver le deuxième donc là on a vécu de
trois jours d'angoissé à vous glacer le
sang vraiment on a on a ont physiquement
on était à l'éternité mal parce que le
on avait l'estomac noué on a et c'est à
ce moment là qu'on a commencé de prier
quoi alors que ce n'était pas tellement
pratique en avant est bon ben on s'est
retrouvés face à face à face à une
perspective de la mort et on a privé ça
nous a ça nous apaiser j'irai moralement
et ça nous permettait déjà un petit peu
de sortir cette cette angoisse est
heureusement deux jours après bon notre
gardien est venu nous voir vous pourrez
commencer à l'est on lui a dit que ça
n'allait pas bien et on lui a dit on
craint pour notre vie et nous a fait
signe de la main ne vous inquiétez pas
on lui a demandé si les contacts étaient
rompus dit non et le dinh shalala ça va
ça va continuer ça c'est le pire moment
le meilleur moment c'était quoi abbas et
la libération de la libération il n'y a
pas eu un bon moment malgré tout pendant
la détention et ctc il ya eu il ya eu
jeudi on a on a rit on a pleuré on a été
traités ont été maltraités c'était assez
surréaliste parfois parce qu'on était on
est très bien traitée lorsqu'on était
dans la cellule de l'armée islamique
dans le dans le nord avec des gens qui
sont quand même des kits eu assez
facilement on nous traitait bien on nous
avons nous appris
je suis une fois on les nourrit nos
ravisseurs ont dit on va aux chocs
caisse de quoi vous avez besoin
non on n'a besoin de rien simplement si
vous pouvez ouvrir l'app un don qui
avait comme ça toujours
sur elle et c'est assez surréaliste
c'était assez surréaliste quand même
c'est quand même quand ils vous ont dit
voilà maintenant il faut que les
français abolissent la loi sur le voile
et 6 abolisse pas la loi voulait tuer
quand même extraordinaire parce que
qu'est l'état pourrait obéir à un tel
ultimatum aucun c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on lui a dit oh je vais
répondu à celui qu'on appelait le gros
qui faisait les cassettes
je lui ai dit si vous a si vous nous
tuez vous n'allez pas abroger la loi et
parce qu'on avait 17 ans il n'y avait
pas le décor en guerrier qu'on voit par
exemple avec les otages américains et
serra s'est déjà au bout de dix jours
donc on donc le type me dit ça il veut
dire si tu dis pas ça vous allez tuer
aussi chirac aboli pas là la loi vous
allez tuer julie mais bon si tu l'a
abolie si tu n'es tu es tu vas pas bien
la mdi we use your on vous utilise donc
là j'ai compris que
que c'était plus c'était une manoeuvre
pour créer un écran de fumée est donc
bon bah évidemment j'ai dit que tout ce
que le tout le mal que je pensais de
cette loi évidemment et puis rick qu'il
fallait que je le président lee qui
abolissent mais on n'a pas pris cette
cassette que vous verrez ici en france
le 30 donc dix jours après notre capture
comme comme une grosse baffe comme celle
du 8 9 ans on a bien analysé on s'est
dit cherche à créer un écran de fumée
parce que parce qu'on leur disait les
français ne sont pas là donc qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous reprocher donc on
s'est dit ils sont en train de créer une
sorte de d'écran de fumée pour pouvoir
pour voir quelle était la réaction en
france quand il fallait ils ont dit à
christian on veut voir les réactions
donc on a bien analysé ce qui fait que
la nuit d'après on n'a pas bon on a on a
on s'est battu avec les moustiques
pendant deux heures comme tous les soirs
et puis après on a donné mais est-ce que
vous avez été victime du syndrome de
stockholm ce regard du tout pas du tout
non non on n'avait aucun moment vous
n'avez pris fait et cause pour non pas
du tout on n'avait pas ce qu on s'est
rapidement rendu compte que le
le gardien aussi agréable avec nous soit
il reste un gardien et s'il reçoit un
ordre il peut nous demander qu'est ce
qu'on veut pour au marché ci reçoit un
ordre de nous tranché la gorge de ce
gardien qui était sympathique avec nous
il faut le dire
on le surnommait aussi le gros parce
qu'il était très grossesse de bibendum
avec des cheveux en brosse j'ai réussi à
voir son visage une fois
un autre des ravisseurs de dire on le
surnomme le boucher parce qu'il est il a
tué et mangé des vipères gérard est
d'accord donc on avait rapidement
conscience que ces gens là étaient très
versatile et qu'il n'y avait pas mais
simplement nous tactiquement on essayait
de de parler avec eux et de me donner
des gages pour que voilà rien seulement
c'est lui qui vous dit que les chrétiens
ont déclaré la guerre aux musulmans en
tchétchénie en afghanistan et que les
musulmans sont légitime défense c'est le
sait le djihad hisser le dans la même au
même moment en octobre lorsqu'on est
dans cette cellule dans le nord deux
dans le vent à l'ouest de bagdad et il
nous dit effectivement
l'occident nous a déclaré la guerre en
tchétchénie en palestine en irak et
caetera et
nous on est on est en état de légitime
défense dont l'un doit on doit vous
attaquer mais on doit pas perdre son
temps à vous attaquer il a fait un signe
comme ça sur le doigt et il faut
attaquer stratégique c'était peu après
le après tabac il me dit comme en
espagne et puis un autre soir il rend il
est venu nous chercher dans notre
cellule et il le dit basse bonne et on
va on va discuter donc on s'installe
devant lui et il y avait le gros
derrière avec son pistolet mais dans une
ambiance où là et il nous dit comment
vous vous sentez psychologiquement alors
lui dise ça va on ne sont pas trop mal
vous nous traitez pas trop bas mais on
comprend pas pourquoi la porte ne
s'ouvre pas et lui dit non vous êtes une
carte politique on va voilà et puis il
nous dit aussi
interrogé moi parce que je sais que ça
va être publié demain donc on lui a dit
écoutez on va vous poser les questions
donc c'était trois semaines avant
l'élection de bush on lui a dit bon pour
qui tu votes bouchaud kerry le dit non
je on vote pour bush nous parce qu'on
met où on préfère bouge parce qu'avec
bouche des soldats américains vont
rester en irak donc ça permettra de nous
renforcer et donc qu'on lui a dit aussi
il parlait de dents que leur objectif
était de recréer un petit peu tout le
califat du sud de l'espagne jusqu'à la
frontière chinoise donc de renverser
tous les régimes arabes et donc on
enregistrait puis y aura un moment on a
essayé de détendre un peu l'atmosphère
liée la france alors et on lui a dit
vrai la france ont en 732 on a arrêté
les arabes à poitiers l'anc fait
attention quoi donc y avait cet échange
est et il me dit nous dit encore une
fois vous êtes connu alors là on lui
répond j'ai dit c'est très bien d'être
connue mais si je rentre dans un
cercueil ça me fait une belle jambe
hélas il était un petit peu dire non
t'inquiète pas si je devais être tuée
j'aurais déjà posé ma cagoule ah ouais
donc c'était évidemment si si si je
t'assure c'est rassurant voilà ça les a
rassurés alors il vous explique que
l'islam est une religion mieux que la
religion chrétienne etc ils essayent de
vous endoctrinés d'une certaine façon
oui oui c'est ça mais bon on a eu aussi
une fois la visite du de celui qui nous
a été présenté comme le boss comme le
chef de l'armée islamique au début et
nous on s'attend à un discours politique
sur le l'occupation américaine
là on aurait pu s'expliquer et là on
voit un type qui arrivent plutôt jeunes
atteint assez assez pâle et qui nous qui
nous fait une leçon 10 points sur la
supériorité effectivement de l'islam par
rapport à la chrétienté a sorti à la fin
d'une demande de conversion vie ça
pourrait aider pour votre libération ça
faisait un petit peu déstabilisé par ce
qu'on s'est dit bon et puis nous a dit
au fond va vous donner un coran
donc allez christian s'est regardés on
s'est dit bon bah s'ils reviennent on
leur dira que quand on n'a rien contre
l'islam ce qui est vrai mais qu'on a
besoin moi que je suis fiancée j'ai
besoin d'en parler à mon nez future
femme quand on sera rentré en france on
ira voir le recteur de la mosquée de
paris on en discutera tout ça on a
essayé un petit peu d'enchaînements ils
sont jamais venus c'était pour nous
déstabiliser qu'autre chose maintenant
il y avait toujours ce y avait toujours
un petit peu 7,7 cette ambivalence entre
on vous traite assez bien mais d'un
autre côté on vous menace donc c'était
des flics quoi en tant que chrétien
vouloir pardonner à vos geôliers oui je
crois leur pardonne je leur pardonne
leur pardonne je leur ses regrets de ne
pas avoir exécuté
et d'avoir compris que la position de la
france n'était pas celle de des états
unis et donc donc j'ai pas de nom j'ai
pas de ressentiment s'est pas non
maintenant dans mon tempérament et
dès qu'on a été capturé on s'est dit il
faut penser à la libération il faut il
faut être positif
il faut s'expliquer il faut bien montrer
que la france n'a rien à voir avec du
conflit et puis se dire que qu'on a un
ange gardien et que vient il va nous
protéger justement le problème de toute
cette histoire c'est comment vous
français donc ressortissant d'un pays
anti guerre vous avez pu être capturé
garder 124 jours en plus vous vous êtes
plutôt sympathisants de la cause la
cause arabe la cause palestinienne veut
dire vous n'êtes pas la légalité
internationale en palestine comme en
irak c'est ce qu'on leur a dit en rade
et de la guerre était illégale donc
l'occupation qui s'ensuit est illégale
et et en palestine c'est la même chose
ya des résolutions de l'onu elles ne
sont pas appliquées depuis 1967 dont on
avait une position claire et non non
c'est ça qui est ça qui est bizarre ce
que d'abord français donc payer
anti-guerre ensuite connu pour des
positions disons pas spécialement
sioniste ou pro israélienne ou et malgré
tout vous êtes garder 124 jours c'est
quand même ça le leurs interrogations
alors il ya quelqu'un qui s'y intéresser
qu on va en parler avec lui qui a écrit
un livre là-dessus c'est gérard de
villiers
jardidier bonsoir bonsoir vous
connaissez tous les deux non on a dû se
croiser un jour on s'est croisés j'ai
entendu parler de vous au proche-orient
rend bien bon an mal an plus tôt en
biens étrangers lui ses bouquins ouais
j'ai reconnu les personnages d'ailleurs
alors gérard de villiers vous publié
chez fayard un bouquin qui s'appelle
otages deux points la vérité les secrets
de leur libération alors vous vous étiez
à bagdad vous au moment où j'étais
bagdad j'étais à bagdad un deuxième
partie de septembre donc eux étaient
déjà capturé moi je venais faire un
achat est simple alors voilà pourquoi la
france a mis autant de temps à récupérer
les otages c'est le sujet de votre livre
joueurs de vignes et je vous dit enfin
vous rapporter une phrase de du new york
times si chirac n'arrive pas à faire
libérer les otages qui en sera capable
effectivement nous qu'on vous avait été
pris on s'est dit ça va durer une
semaine la france a une position tout à
fait clair dans la terre etc les raisons
alors il ya plusieurs raisons on va les
prendre une par une la première en fait
c'est que les français les américains
n'ont plus aucune coopération là bas etc
avant de savoir qui étaient les
ravisseurs il a fallu du temps mais je
pense pas que ce soit la raison c'est
une raison nous américains n'ont pas
aidé c'est certain ouais mais ce n'est
pas pour ça qu'on n'a pas organisé à
lens ils continueront les raisons donc
il ya une autre raison qui est que
l'ambassadeur de france en irak bernard
bajolet était pas en irak justement
était pas à bagdad il était à paris pour
la fameuse conférence des ambassadeurs
il ya lieu tous les ans et donc c'est le
chargé d'affaires qui étaient là bas ça
ça a dû effectivement pas facilité les
choses
c'est à dire que le chargé d'affaires a
commis une erreur à mon sens mineurs
parfaitement excusable parce qu'il faut
comprendre une chose sans que les gens
le sachent les règles du jeu venait de
changer parce que avant leur enlèvement
aucun journaliste français n'avait été
enlevés pour plus de 24 48 heures donc
se charger de faire acquis au vient dire
que deux journalistes ont été kidnappés
par un groupe inconnu
et demande en demandant peu de choses
donne en mille dollars résultat ça lui
paraît sa loi par hubinon et il était
parfaitement excusable et ça c'est le
plat première course je crois que
l'ambassadeur était la conférence des
ambassadeurs mai
mais rapidement le contact a été pris le
lundi on est venu nous voir et on a
signé un petit morceau de papier sur
lequel on inscrivait georges malbrunot
hockey la signature on les a dits safa
la fringue si l'ambassade de france donc
le le contact a été établi rapidement et
je crois que il faut pas incriminer tel
diplôme à tout et l'on cherche enfin moi
perso j'étais quand même un petit peu
concerné dans cette affaire perdant donc
je pense que ça s'est vraiment je crois
qu'on va former autre raison est ce que
l'un d'eux est ce que l'appel de chirac
suppliant les ravisseurs est-ce que ça a
fait monter les enchères ça a donné du
poids
je crois que il ya eu une période de ce
que j'appelle la livre diluvio lyrique
en gros c'est chirac s'est dit et son
entourage la classe politique française
tout le monde se dit mais les arabes
peuvent pas nous faire ça ouais nous
sommes leurs amis et les gens n'ont pas
réalisé que les arabes il ya plusieurs
catégories 1 et que pour des gens comme
ceux qui les ont enlevés
c'est à dire des salafistes des gens du
takfir des extrémistes nous faisons
partie de la caravane de septembre alors
autre raison et et non la moindre en
tous les cas pour vous chers de villiers
c'est que le ministère des affaires
étrangères le quai d'orsay a voulu
garder le dossier alors qu'ils n'ont
jamais résolu dites-vous aucune prise
d'otage est en fait la
dgse les servettiens la dgse les
services secrets ont été mis sur le coup
très longtemps après à d'ailleurs tapé
sur la table pour que rondo soit envoyée
avec rando à jouer un rôle je dirais
marginal et la joue un rôle d'expert
parce qu'il connaissait bien le gros
travail a été fait par les gens de la
dgs la dgse a envoyé une formidable
équipe à bagdad dirigée par un type qui
est un très très beau comme on est sympa
j'ai pas envie de vous lire
bien sûr je ne vous le dirais que par
son prénom
rien un indice ça commence par r son nom
commence par air data donc il envoie
là-bas ils en voient pas tout seul et
eux dont c'est le métier parce que une
récupération d'otages c'est une
opération clandestine par destination ce
sont des rendez-vous
tordu secret difficile dangereux bons et
ils se sont mis au travail mais on avait
perdu quand même pendant le temps donc
alors la vraie raison de ses 124 jours
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même freslon genre de misery oui c'est
comme les accidents d'avion n'y a pas
une raison et à une conjonction de
plusieurs la raison en tous les cas il y
en a une autre de raison c'est julia
sens et où la voilà ce que vous avez
d'ascq vous avez la pollution du ca de
la pollution sur six heures d'une inde
du cso les dalton non c'est une
association c'est une association de
malfaiteurs alors mettez dans une
déclaration avec à sa tête un illuminé
pas malhonnête un monsieur julia
mikitani lui est totale crédule et ses
drames et les autres philippe brett moi
je le connais personnellement et à deux
on les premières visa qui m'a jamais eu
donc gelé j'ai pratiqué pendant un
certain temps là l'arrière salle du café
sco s'appelle victor hugo 1 c'est un
voyou son boulot c'était d'amener des
français chez saddam et de pas de faire
du bizness pentes des cols et après le
vendée interview bidon de saddam qui n'a
perdent pas que hier s'avère tout le
monde c'est vrai que ça me donnait pas
d'interview donc là il a cherché là où
il a vu une occasion de se remettre en
scène c'est à dire que vous on était
dans une phase de libération quand il ya
eu cette affaire philippe brett
julia et sa retarder votre libération
c'est clair ça a retardé un petit peu
mais je suis pas convaincu j'alerte
aller tant que ça que tout ça ça fait
partie de ces imposteurs ya eu des
dizaines qui sont allés à l'ambassade de
france dira oui j'ai vu malbrunot et
chesneau j'ai mangé du crous avec lui et
j'ai besoin de changer ne sont pas
maîtres à ses terres
vous savez thierry au bonheur c'est tout
ce qui avait un morceau de la vraie
croix ouais il y en avait une
soixantaine alors bon au départ comme
l'elysée est au courant de la vente sûrs
didier julia philippe brett et en se
disant c'est bien d'avoir deux fers au
feu mais quand ils voient que ça tourne
mal il laisse tomber m en france la
classe politique française à la culture
du mensonge ce qui est très dommage
parce que personne ne peut blâmer ni
chirac ni les gens chargés du dossier
d'avoir tenté tout même s'il y avait une
chance sur un million mais fait des
intempéries ont l'ambition a reçu de
matinée alors si vous étiez prêts
nouveaux services nierait avoir une
connaissance de mon âge et c'est tout
alors ça c'est tout simplement ils
avaient raison de tenter même si vu
toute petite chance 1 il n'avait qu'à
dire après bien sûr on a tout en arrêt
mais personne ne peut rien reprocher la
raison la raison majeure de villiers
est-ce que dernière question est ce
qu'il ya eu rançon ou parents sont pas
ce que vous ce que vous dites c'est
finalement comme ça a été à la fin un
échange physique c'est à dire que si
vous n'étiez pas eu rançon ils auraient
pu les laisser au bord de la route
finalement mais le fait qu'ils aient
exigé de les remettre en main propre
c'est parce qu on échange on devait leur
donner quelque chose c'est votre moi
j'en suis persuadé je n'étais pas là
donc je peux pas le signer avec mon sens
et je n'ai jamais encore vu d'histoire
de tâches qui se termine sans une remise
de compensation est au contraire un mois
j'ai pas vu de jésus des valises avec de
l'argent dedans j'ai vu un coup un
coffre qui s'est levé on est sorti et on
c'est à vous allez ça sent bon la kia
semble acquis
il y avait quand même d'un peu de
nervosité parce qu'il fait des ddd pas
mal de deux mains de petits pandas et
les italiens il ya une rançon pour
récupérer leur dû ah oui tout de suite
la berlusconi lui la police a pris trois
semaines mais il y aura moins ils en ont
marre oui mais moi je trouve ça là c'est
tout à fait normal de payer une rançon
pour récupérer de réussir de deux
nationaux d'autant que l'ânesse cette
affaire le tue le suivi de la faire ça a
coûté une fortune
les gens elle a fait déplacer des gens
il ya eu des défauts ferait si on peut
dire plus tout ce qu'il fallait verser
ou faux intermédiaire mais qu en est il
arrivé à l'ambassade de france avec un
petit truc prouvant qu'il avait un
contact avec les ravisseurs qu'ils aient
ces 5000 $ on pouvait pas le virer 1
c'était c'était des étoiles filantes la
plupart qu'on ne voyait jamais mêlant
delà là aussi principe de précaution ont
été obligés tous suivre et c'est un
certain dgse a fait un travail de tri
oui c'est ce que vous êtes trop
d'acteurs de la neige est réservé un
beau travail c'est un très beau travail
de professionnels bien merci genre de
villiers merci d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle le tigre cuivre otage la vie
c'est publié chez fayard
non
cette affaire à george v à paris voilà
qui ouvre
alors c'est vraiment passé on avait reçu
sa main abdul majeed le traducteur de
saddam hussein dans cette émission ça
avait été très dur d'ailleurs pour
qu'ils viennent parce qu'il était à
londres beaucoup de mal pour avoir le
pouvoir le visa et c'est un livre qui
avait été fait en collaboration avec
christian chesnot et vous georges
malbrunot publié chez fayard voilà
alors j'espère toi maintenant
je vais continuer de m'occuper du
moyen-orient depuis paris et ce n'est
sans aller en s'en aller en irak parce
que la situation est devenue impossible
pour les journalistes 20 on nous a dit
d'ailleurs ne revenez pas l'irak est
devenue la terre de la guerre et on n'a
pas besoin de vos copains que je vais
pas tenter le diable deux fois alors que
roger auque il y retourne et lui avec un
fait et laurier une fille de libé
florence aubenas qui a été donc kidnappé
7 le problème c'est que les journalistes
ne peuvent plus travailler parce que le
le le les conditions de déplacement sont
venus très difficiles et les ces
groupes-là qui prennent en otage sont
postés à différents endroits ont des
rabatteurs et c'est bon la pêche donc
cessé dans notre cas par exemple moi
c'était c'était je savais qu'à cet
endroit là il y avait des risques mais
on avait tellement travaillé un petit
peu avant on était sur un rythme un
petit peu au-delà du supportable et j'ai
baissé la garde au mauvais moment au
mauvais endroit et je suis resté dix
minutes aux au téléphone et ils sont dit
voilà il ya un étranger et puis ils ont
chopé quoi pour ma gouverne personnel
vous avez été enlevé à honor le
latifiyah au sud est y fiez pas c'était
c'était je crois au sud de latifiyah mai
mais on a été enlevée je crois qu'il est
pas ya beaucoup de thèses qui ont
circulé dans l'avion on a lu des choses
enfin un petit peu invraisemblable et on
a été dès le début arrêté par l'armée
islamique en irak qui a des gens qui
capturent des gens qui jugent des gens
qui gardent les gens qui voient là je
crois que c'est une armée qui est qui et
qui est organisée qui s'est structurée
au fil des mois et qui a un système où
on expliquait on à on ya un type qui
vient vous interrogeait et il remet
c'est un juge d'instruction il remet son
sont ces conclusions un tribunal composé
d'un ensemble de chair de responsables
religieux et tribaux et qu'ils jugent
ils jugent avec ses deux cases la nation
est où
ouh ouh négociations et on l'a vu après
alors il ya aussi ces lorient où sa
veille à l'organisation puis elle bordel
on a on a réussi par l'en à savoir une
fois où est-ce qu'on était parce que nos
gardiens ont laissé traîner comme ça des
ddd plastique le matin en nous servant
le plus mais on avait eu bekri rabat
deux quartiers de bagdad et moi je
connais un petit peu bagdad et je me
suis dit on n'est pas dans le on n'est
pas avant de tourner dans le quartier
est plus qu'un jour après un soir on
reçoit un jour soit notre traditionnel
poulet riz et puis se démarquer
boucherie mustapha à la mairie a donc il
y à aussi ça donc j'ai eu c'est une
structure qui s'organise mais aussi avec
avec aussi le lin l'inorganisation qui
est un petit peu là la règle au
moyen-orient sur merci merci jammes et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux